the stock market hit major turbulence
this week nursing some steep losses and
sharp rebounds following a rocky start
to the new year it is a far cry from the
study gains that we saw through most of
2021. so when the federal reserve's
policymakers met today investors were
counting on the central bank to explain
how it's going to address rising
inflation to get insight into what came
out of the meeting and how that will
affect the stock market let's bring in
bloomberg's bailey lip shultz bailey
thanks so much for joining us i want to
start on the anticipation heading into
today's fed meeting did central banker
jay powell provide enough clarity for
investors moving forward
yes and no they came out saying that
investors should expect a rate hike soon
you should read that as march but the
main question from investors was how
rapid will these rate hikes uh take
place and from fedshare powell they
basically left the door open for
multiple rate hikes at every meeting or
excuse me a rate hike at every meeting
and that caused some concern for
investors because they had gotten so
accustomed to jay powell on the fed
using some uh typical language that
assured the market of a gradual approach
everything was going to take place at a
very calculated pace and some of the
commentary in the question and answer
today with fed chair powell was that
investors really should buckle up for
the potential of a rate hike
consecutively at meeting after meeting
okay so he signaled that we could get
steady rate increases but there was also
a lot of uncertainty about what that
might look like going forward because we
don't know how inflation will shake out
explain to me why higher interest rates
would prompt stocks to fall though
well when you look at investing so
typically
interest rates when they're higher make
stock markets less attractive and that's
really what we've been seeing when you
look back to november when fed uh
initially kind of signaled that
investors should get ready for uh
additional interest rate hikes in 2022
and 2023 that's why we saw a lot of the
high-tech uh high-growth tech stocks
really fall under pressure those are
companies that are preferred uh by the
likes of kathy wood um read that as a
company like a robin hood or
non-profitable tech companies because
when you're investing when interest
rates are higher those profits that are
coming in 2024 2025 and 2026 look less
attractive in the near term and that
really has been the main messaging from
investors that i've been talking to and
inflation is only going up the latest
read shows consumer prices rising seven
percent it seems like a lot of people
have been caught by surprise at how
persistent it is when prices first
started rising there was this fun debate
over whether it's temporary transitory
now it seems pretty clear that it's here
to stay but what is the investor
confidence that raising interest rates
is going to cool inflation moving
forward
it's really mixed because there are
still concerns around supply chain
supply chains were initially a big
factor that drove inflation and drove
products that you and individual
consumers were buying higher and now
we're seeing not only producers or not
only
sellers raising prices but they're kind
of passing along those costs to in
consumers and that's one of the things
that investors are unsure of when you
look at it from a generalist investing
standpoint uh rate hikes should help
ease some of the inflation but we're
still kind of in uncharted territory
just given the unprecedented nature of a
pandemic like we saw with covet 19 as we
continue to come out of it and as
employment really runs near
what said chair jay powell said is
likely maximum employment yeah the
reasons behind the inflation are
different this time because we're in a
pandemic that and we haven't seen this
kind of situation play out before in a
long time
billy there are obviously a lot of cross
currents when it comes to the stock
market interest rates and what the
federal reserve says and does is just
one part of the picture
you've also got companies reporting
financial earnings and you mentioned a
couple of them earlier we're getting a
lot of earnings coming in this week has
been super busy for all the companies
that are reporting uh their financial
results it's kind of like giving the
report card to investors can you distill
an overarching message from the
companies that have reported banks like
jp morgan or
tech companies like microsoft what is
the message from them
the big takeaway from banks is that
they're spending a lot of money to
retain talent and they're keeping a
close eye on what consumers are doing
whether that's taking on debt to go out
and buy a new car or maybe make a huge
purchase like buying a house
that really was the main message coming
from banks but when you look at a
company like microsoft yesterday really
shot the lights out with stellar
earnings growth a seller outlook for
2022 it came at the right time for a lot
of these tech companies that are
invested uh by pretty much everyone in
the in the us whether you're looking at
a microsoft or a facebook a google those
companies are continuing to deliver and
it'll be particularly interesting this
week as we get results from an apple
looking at what the outlook looks like
as these companies kind of go through
any supply chain issues and make real
broad statements on where they see
consumers in 2022 but obviously the
market is just about 10 off record highs
hit earlier in the year so there is
still a little bit of trepidation about
what growth will look like and how
active u.s consumers will be in spending
well also the stock market as a whole
has had a lot of blockbuster years from
2019 to 2020-2021
what are the experts you talked to
saying about the likelihood of stocks
finding their footing to post yet
another year of gains
the main thing that i'm hearing from
people that i'm talking to on wall
street is that there should still be
optimism that 2022 can deliver gains and
end the year higher than where it came
in the main question is the near term
we're hearing from a lot of portfolio
managers saying they expect a choppy
next two three four months i was talking
to a couple people who helped uh take
companies public and they said they're
really setting their sights on what
april will bring what will the economy
look like in april here in the u.s and
globally as we potentially deal with uh
future variants of covid as people
continue to adjust to a potentially or
another likely rate hike from an
investment standpoint and as we really
get a better grip on what the u.s
economy and what the global economy is
looking like again as we continue to
hopefully step forward um from what has
been a brutal pandemic all things being
cleared
you know one thing that we've seen since
uh the bottom of the stock market is
that every time you see some kind of dip
we see buyers come in an army of buyers
come in to bid prices higher it's called
buying the dip right and it's worked so
well over the last couple of years this
year however we're looking at the stock
market nursing losses for 2022. why is
buy the dip not working
we're not seeing is the same rush from
both retail investors and wall street
pros there's a lot of uncertainty about
again what will the next month two
months three months look like we are
hearing from retail traders that they
are putting money into broad etfs that
track things like the s p 500 things
that track the nasdaq 100 but we're not
seeing the robust demand to buy a dip
and snatch up a dip because again there
still is so much uncertainty of what the
fed will do how will the real economy be
shaped by fed rate [ __ ] uh by inflation
there's just a general uh uncertainty
and obviously the market doesn't like
uncertainty but scarlett one thing i
personally am uh really keen to see is
what will we see on monday and tuesday
of next week as it is the end of the
month in the beginning of february when
people tend to get paid we normally see
retail investors buy more dips when
checks hit their bank accounts so
that'll be an interesting signal for me
for me to see if some of those retail
investors will be stepping back in like
we have seen for really the last year
bailey do you anticipate individual
investors giving up on stocks and moving
into other investments like commodities
nfts crypto
uh it doesn't seem to be that way i talk
to a lot of individual investors who are
on things like twitter stock twits
wall street bets and if you are into the
cryptocurrency space or if you're into
something like nfts there is definitely
a demand from people who are into that
kind of an asset but generally speaking
what i'm seeing and hearing more from
individual investors are they're selling
ideas of the kathy woods they're selling
these high-flying growth stocks that
they have seen shoot up over the last
few years and are really putting their
money into kind of easy calm investments
like again ets that track the broader
market etfs that have a little bit of
balance even if they're tech skewed
because it's easier to kind of put cash
in make sure your money's going into
that and not worry too much about the
ups and downs especially if you're an
individual investor with a longer term
horizon who doesn't necessarily sweat
the uh 10 correction in a month all
right bailey well thank you so much for
joining us and giving us the much needed
context on that meeting today really
appreciate it that was bailey lip
schultz joining us for more on the feds
meeting today
you